raphael fame an ihr thema ist heute
ebenfalls das einschränken ihr thema
sind lebensmittel sie sind lebensmittel
retter so darf ich sie einmal bezeichnet
so es glaube ich selbst auch und sie
sagen wir stehen vor einer gewaltigen
hunger krise genauso wir stehen nicht
nur vor einer gewaltigen hunger krise
bestehen in einer sehr großen hunger
krise die es schon seit jahrzehnten gibt
wir haben fast eine milliarde menschen
die tagtäglich nicht genügend nahrung zu
sich nehmen kann weil es an wasser fehlt
an grundnahrungsmitteln das heißt wir
befinden uns das schon ist nicht so dass
wir da gerade rein schnell und es wird
noch schlimmer gerade durch die ukraine
krise ist das potenzial dass noch mehr
menschen an unterernährung sterben sind
schon millionen euro pro jahr leider
auch dieses jahr wieder nicht überleben
werden und man muss auch dazu sagen
lebensmittelverschwendung ist ein riesen
thema was auch damit zusammenhängt dass
leute auch in anderen teilen der erde
hungern nämlich 50 prozent aller
lebensmittel die wir hier in europa
produzieren und die wir importieren
werden nicht gegessen das ist in
deutschland eine lkw-ladung pro minute
was für ein lebensmittel verschwenden
und das ist in euro ungefähr 300 euro
die wir pro person in deutschland in die
tonne schmeißen an lebensmittel und dies
gleichzeitig obwohl wir eine milliarde
menschen haben die an unterernährung
leiden und deswegen diesen globalen
zusammenhang zu sehen wir können es uns
ökonomisch leisten und so viel
wegzuschmeißen aber ethisch und
ökologisch ist es eine vollkatastrophe
den zehn prozent aller globalen
treibhausgase entstehen durch die
lebensmittelverschwendung
aber noch einmal ganz kurz die frage was
noch mal klar zu machen wann kommt jetzt
wie diese die hungerkrise ist volle
kanne darf volle lotte und dies in den
letzten jahren sogar noch schlimmer
geworden food waste
lebensmittelverschwendung wir haben 2,5
milliarden tonnen jedes jahr die
wegschmeißen und es steigt durch den
wohlstand in der gesellschaft in auf
fast allen kontinenten steigt die
lebensmittelfirma frauen hungerkrise
gleich lebensmittelverschwendung kann
man diese gleichung überhaupt
es ist sehr einfach gesprochen dass in
diesem blog haft blog bildhaft
dargestellt
man muss doch ganz einfach sehen
natürlich haben wir probleme aber ich
verlange garantiere ich denke eben nicht
in apocalypse szenarien sondern ich sage
ihnen voraus sowie jaberg heute morgen
angekündigt hat sie wissen dass
wahrscheinlich dass die laufzeiten für
kohlekraftwerke und gaskraftwerke
verlängert werden dass die beschlüsse
die jetzt bis 24 voraus es wird also
weiter kohle weil die normative kraft
des faktischen zwingt dieser zu wenn die
industrie kaputt geht das licht ausgeht
sind die straßen von leuten voll das
kann ich ihnen sagen was damit passiert
dann gibt es auch in der wissenschaft
weiter ich meine gegen theesen zu ihnen
ist ich sehe einen durchbruch der
gentechnik wir werden aus einem
samenkorn vier
ernten
das wird alles hier ja in deutschland
verschwiegen
da bin ich richtig im fernsehen wir sind
ja ich bin ja ich bin sehr
sensibilisiert sagen nein nicht was das
bringen als die letzte bastion
insofern muss man sagen es gäbe würden
wir verschweigen dass sie haben nicht
nur die klugen leute es gibt so haben
auch ganz andere die in laboren sitzen
die arbeiten das wird einen tisch
gekehrt weil die vorstellung dieser
leute ist natürlich eine andere welt
eine andere gesellschaft und darum geht
es im wesentlichen über m wie wir einst
empfehlen seit acht jahren sind sie
vegan zehn ja seit zehn jahren haben sie
noch fünf jahre bis sie wahrscheinlich
krank werden ich wünsche es ihnen also
ich bin seit zwei jahren nur zweimal
corona erkranken sonst durchgehend ja
gesund die fünf jahre ich habe gesagt
nach 15 jahren vegan wird bei ihm ein
chronischer mangel beten solle auf jeden
fall nehme ich aber daran ist ganz
wichtig aber nicht wirklich nicht als
solche ihre diese konten seiner kunden
zu mögen sich zu bieten der leber
gespeichert und nach 15 jahren
speicherung vorrat wird fast so der
mediziner
die frage ist das was auch georg astrein
sagte und christian lohse gerade das ist
beispielsweise fleisch aus dem
reagenzglas gibt oder
ist das aber die lösung horror gewählt
werden
ich kann noch nicht sagen wo sie sehen
ist gesteht die eine dame solardach
sondern es ist ein boden von
verschiedenen möglichkeiten wie jeder
einzelne wie wir als gesellschaft
unseren ökologischen fußabdruck
reduzieren können damit unsere kinder
und kindeskinder auch noch sich hier auf
diesem wunderbaren bis nehmen was ich an
den rechtshänder ist wasser in der
dritten welt ist die meisten kinder
sterben an der qualität des wassers
nämlich an cholera ich war in diesen
gebieten ich habe afrika besucht aber
wie sehr gerade im verein gesagt
klimakrise ist eigentlich unser system
ist nicht die frage dass wasser das
schlecht ist
alles immer überstülpen klima ist jetzt
plötzlich das bringt aber
es gibt einen ökologischen fußabdruck
aber es gibt auch ein wasser fußabdruck
zum beispiel ein kilo fleisch verbraucht
15 bis 20 000 von dem ring liter wasser
und dieses wasser kommt nicht aus
deutsche weil die kamen hier steht
sondern das futter kommt aus anderen
ländern außerhalb nun eben weil ein jahr
nicht gemacht
unsere oder liegt ja die wir hier ein
von dem nun ernähren überhaupt wer so
anna waldmann klar zu halten um dem
lager das vielleicht etwas zu bündeln es
geht also am ende um verzicht wir müssen
nicht hungern verzichten geliefert warum
gesprochen die frage ist verzicht also
das ist ja der punkt hunger ist was ganz
anderes nochmal ich glaub freiwillig wir
haben 30 300.000 menschen gab die sich
vegetarisch ernähren vor 30 jahren
mittlerweile sind es zwischen fünf und
zehn millionen menschen aber freiwillig
tun sie es und zwar verzicht kommt immer
so ich würde gerne dies tun ich würde
das gern essen aber ich kann es nicht
weil es mir leisten gehen ist das für
mich verdient das ist ein deutscher
aspekt das sehe ich ganz anders also
erst mal wenn wir zusammen ist und regen
egal was wir tun erst mal die erste
grund register mülleimer ist nicht
besser als die gäste fangen mit der
gleichheit mal sehr pragmatisch gesehen
und wenn wir zum beispiel ein
schmorbraten am sonntag war der motor
dies und donnerstag in essen aber
entscheidend ist das vielleicht mit vier
sechs oder acht oder zwölf personen am
tisch sitzen und wie sozialisieren auch
also ein seelen wer aber dass
sozialisieren und dazu ist der esstisch
hervorragend gemacht wir lernen zu
strahlen gelernt zu essen zu trinken wir
lernen zu sozialisieren und unsere
mitmenschen zu respektieren und
gleichzeitiges wenn wir miteinander
sprechen
wir haben essen was zugänglich ist was
auch geduldig ist was ich erklärt werden
muss diese künftig das turnier dieses
dieser ganze quatsch dann haben wir
einen ganz schönen tag für uns und wir
gehen gestärkt von der seele vom geist
und vom körper jahr mit guter grund
nahrung in die woche hinein und ich bin
der meinung wir müssen nicht jeden
morgen unsere schinken steuer essen und
nicht eben mehr anschlüsse lassen oder
drei stattdessen die kleine reduktion
und auch das verteilen von gutem essen
tut und wenn wir dann noch sozialisieren
dazu und der esstisch bewegt einen dazu
zu sanieren auch der austausch und das
vernünftige streitgespräch zu führen ich
finde das ist eine ganz tolle sache so
erreichen sie denn ich rede von der
französischen kultur die menschen
dagegen kaum noch zusammen essen kommen
auf zusammen aber es gibt nur erst
umfrage weise dass das dass menschen
wegen des schocks und in großbritannien
wissen wir sind lebensmittel dem stimmt
auch deutsche deutlich teurer als bei
uns eine mahlzeit ausfallen lassen jetzt
zeigen sie hier ich zeige mal in die
heißeste zeitung berlin star aus der met
und auch in der bild war das heute sehen
sie darauf freut sich deutschland morgen
am vatertag deutschland grillt und den
das ist aus der bz in der bild ist noch
viel größer mit fleischstücken die
abgebildet sind jetzt frage ich sie
wollen sie den menschen diese freude
nehmen
deutsche habe ich mich noch genau hier
aber grill aber die platte ist ja und
das heißt wir stehen alle um ihn herum
und wie sozialisiert wird auch für mich
sehr aufregend für die jungen da müsste
ich
natürlich
gerne gemüse dazu
nicht mehr so sind dass man sie
eigentlich essen kann schmeißen sie dann
weg ich schmeiße sicherlich auch mal
lebensmitteln leider recht wenn es
stellt sich an alles geht ich glaube was
was sich für mich die frage stellt ist
eigentlich wenn wir so viel abfall
produzieren wie sie es gerade gesagt
haben dann ist das eigentlich auch
volkswirtschaftlich eine ganz große
ineffizienz das heißt die frage ist wie
schaffen wir es denn abfall zu
reduzieren und dann ist das nämlich
keine moralische oder moralapostel
einstellung sondern das ist einfach nur
ein effizienterer falls volkswirtschaft
die wir besser mal angehen aber glauben
sie nicht dass die verbraucher und das
ist ja immer dass wir sehen beim benzin
mittlerweile auch die deutschen fahren
wenig der auto sie tanken weniger weil
benzin so teuer geworden ist glauben sie
nicht auch dass eigentlich jeder
verbraucher das schon in gewisser weise
selbst macht weil er wenn er feststellt
lebensmittel sind teurer geworden ich
schmeiße aber gleichzeitig viel zu viel
weg dass das sich am ende doch auf dem
markt damit in der noch einmal ein könig
reisen ich glaube leider ist zurzeit
nicht überall die anreiz setzung so wenn
wir zum beispiel jetzt mal unseren
unsere elektrischen geräte nähmen jahr
zum beispiel ein ipad dann ist es
zurzeit günstiger neues ipad zum teil zu
kaufen und gegenüber lebensmitteln als
es zu reparieren das ist ja ok aber es
geht hier um abfall im allgemeinen auch
erst mal klassisch für immer bis jetzt
recyceln sie noch nicht bis jetzt retten
sie lebensmittel oder wir retten leben
einmal das thema essen aber okay dann
haben wir hier also ein bürger der sich
engagiert dafür dass wir
lebensmittelabfälle irgendwie reduzieren
oder oder nochmal neu verwerten ja und
ich glaube so was kann man aber auch
eben anreize schaffen von der politik
und wie sagt auch schon jetzt da kenne
ich mich eben jetzt besser ausbreiten
repair also ein verbraucherrecht darauf
dass ich das nicht habe etwas zu
reparieren eine kaputte waschmaschine
und so weiter und dass das dann
günstiger ist als neues produkt zu
kaufen im abfall lebensmittel
abfallrecht hätte ich mich nicht aus
aber sicherlich gibt es da auch anreize
die wahnsinnig einfach sind und die es
uns ermöglichen als deutsche nicht zu
verzichten aber trotzdem weniger abfall
zu generieren und somit vielleicht auch
einfach noch ein stück weiter zu denken
und smart zu sein und technologie auch
dafür zu nutzen
nichts anderes habe ich gesagt habe da
kommen wir zurück ich möchte etwas dazu
sagen vor 40 jahren war das erste mal in
meiner tante frau vogt fleischer
meisterin aus und was verdient im kadewe
und dann wir waren alleine abends
zuhause ich wusste mal meinen urlaub
hier verbringen und hat sie gesagt
können wir jetzt keine weg auf mich zu
und sagt wir sind nur zu zweit verkaufen
vier scheiben brot an und das war
möglich im kadewe konnte vier scheiben
brot einkaufen wenn ich jetzt als single
haushalt also ich hab die möglichkeit
ein halbes wohl kaufen oder verkaufen
ganzes brot und was passiert er wird
exzessiv wieder dann schmeckt er nicht
mehr ich wusste ein toaster stecken also
passiert ist genau das passiert genau
das was wir nicht wollen ich weiß dann
weg warum ist es nicht möglich dass sie
mir einfach zwei scheiben abschneiden
sagt kommt nichts wahrscheinlich nach
hause das heißt ja das ist ja eben
selbst belastet doch da hat der kunde
auch immer ein gewisses druckmittel ich
bin da völlig anderer meinung als nicht
klappt muss der staat kann ich glaube
jeder merkt das ja und ich habe das auch
von kollegen uhr legen die einkauf und
sagen mensch ist das einkaufen teurer
geworden das ist doch da bringt man noch
automatisch an sich zu überlegen brauche
ich eigentlich ein ganzes bewohner das
thema ist der mindestens bis und nicht
sofort tödlich ab und welche gar nicht
vergessen dass das
mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum vor 40 jahren
da gab es noch gar nicht da hat man
immer auf seine sinne vertraut man
schaut sie ein produkt an man öffnet das
man schaut man probiert vielleicht
kostet und unser gaumen schmecken
konzert junko diese keller und der
großeltern die nach auch ein normaler er
ist nicht zwei wochen nach immer den
noch genießbar sondern greenpeace hat
studien gemacht acht monate das heißt
die meisten leute wissen gar nicht dass
man die lebensmittel viel länger
genießen kann und das wollen wir auch
mit servers mit fu cheng und die tafel
alle diese initiativen kümmert sich
letztlich darum des bewusstseins level
in der gesellschaft zu steigern weil wir
am ende für 50 prozent der
lebensmittelverschwendung zuhause
verantwortlich also ohne auf um
erziehung abzustellen und ähnliches sind
dinge die über nacht geändert werden
konnten ich habe unlängst diskutieren
mit dem chef der berliner tafel die
nicht sehr lange kenne und er hat noch
chefin
denn sie treten wir reden wir von zwei
verschiedenen veranstaltungen jedenfalls
habe ich es als sicher dass das der das
gemacht hat in pankow die erste ist
wegen der suppenküche der suppenküchen
und tafeln er ist heute und er hat mir
berichtet dass sie aufgrund der vielen
flüchtlinge aus der ukraine
das habe ich noch was zu sanktionen das
war unverschämt was sie wollen gesagt
aber über die sanktion ja aber was
anderes thema es hat mich sehr getroffen
aber
dass die haben die schulter sanktionen
sind auch schuld dass es in der
ernährungskrise ist er in einer so viel
zeit muss sein moment so es ist so wie
ich wollte ich habe viele freunde die
wie er in der hotellerie tätig sind oder
waren
gastronomie zum beispiel im hotel de
rome oder im interconti und ich habe
gedacht ich komme früher war ich
finanziere das und wir holen das jeden
morgen von den buffets allein
weggeschmissen wird dann sagt das darf
ich nicht aus hygienischen gründen denn
es könnte ja der korona warum einer von
den wenigen vorbeikommen und mal wussten
also also wird augenblick bitte und das
bedeutet hier wird verschwendet durch
setze ich habe gesagt dann müssen sie
eben tisch bedienung einführen dann wird
er sagt es ist aber so teuer der
gewerkschaften treiben das so nach oben
mit der entlohnung dass wir uns das
nicht leisten können das ist eine im
system immer wichtiger punkt erfreulich
da ist auch viel zu tun nicht nur dass
lebensmittel retten aber auch die frage
wie geht man eigentlich mit
lebensmitteln um die eigentlich jetzt
wie heißt es so schön ich sage meinen
canaries wird auf dem posten bleiben sie
sitzen zu haben dass ich sie gegessen